你以為ChatGPT只會丟答案?
錯
ChatGPT現在不僅會逼你思考
陪你一起學
還會反問你學懂了沒有
甚至還會出題目考你
今天這集
我們來花5分鐘的時間
帶你立刻上手
直接使用
嗨各位又是我AJ
你有沒有發現過去用ChatGPT的時候
學習這件事情呢
它總是會把所有的標準答案
一次灌給你
你真正能理解多少
說實話
有一點難說
最近呢 OpenAI
終於推出了一個新的模式
叫做
Study and Learn 學習模式
這不是多一個按鈕一個選項
而是整個學習的節奏大改造
直接陪你
拆解問題
反問理解
出題考你
全自動的來一套完整流程
我們今天呢
會從它的核心原理開始
再到實際的操作示範
最後我們會提供幾個高效的使用技巧
讓你把這個功能功效最大化
話不多說
那我們就直接開始吧
OK
直接切入重點
這個學習模式的底層邏輯到底是什麼
說實話
這其實不是什麼
全新的ChatGPT模型
也不是像Deep Research那種
抓一堆資料回來
思考之後
生成一份報告的工具
它真正的秘密
其實就是 OpenAI
在後面塞了一串
超級專業的家教提示語當
系統的背景指令
讓AI變成像一個專職的老師一樣
教學風格大升級
換句話說
如果你自己也很會下 Prompt
其實
說實話
你自己也就可以把ChatGPT
變成你的專屬家教
只是那樣
只會在一個聊天的對話框裡面有效
但學習與研究這個模式
厲害的地方
就是把整套完整的教學邏輯
內建進去ChatGPT裡面
讓你每次學習都能夠自動啟動
不用每次重新打一個非常長的提示語
講到這邊
你還是應該不知道
這個功能到底有什麼特別的
嘿
我們直接來進實作
舉例
如果我們問ChatGPT一個問題
比如說
什麼是SWAT分析
你看
一般ChatGPT
只會直接貼一段答案給你
有點像是無差別攻擊一樣
不管3、7、21
ChatGPT就給你
全盤拖出
但是呢
當我們打開
學習與研究這個功能之後呢
我們再用同樣一段的問題問他
你會發現
他除了給你一些
前顯易懂的解釋之外呢
他還會開始試著回頭問你問題
這種互動
重點是讓你真正理解
而不是只會操答案
所以他不是直接丟答案給你
而是用蘇格拉底問答法
透過反問引導
把你一步步的帶進學習的狀態
這樣的轉變
其實重新定義了AI的角色
從問答引擎
轉變為一個
個人的導師
剛剛我們只是從一句話來看這個功能
開啟前後的差別
難道這學習與研究功能
就只有這樣子而已嗎
當然不是
我們接下來實際演練一個
給各位看看
我想要考多益考到900分
該怎麼辦呢
然後我們開啟學習模式
然後按送出
他會先問我幾個問題
讓我知道怎麼樣幫你設計計劃
其實這個就是這個學習模式
他第一個非常有趣的地方
就是他其實
不會馬上給你結果
而是他會先反問
一些問題
然後透過你給他一些
這些問題的答案之後呢
他才會給你
更加準確的回答內容
比如說我就跟他講說
我現在多益只有550分
所以呢
他就會給我一些這個準備的策略
那需要我幫你找提庫
或是整理背單字清單嗎
重點就在這裡啦
我們要他的題庫
所以他就第一天給我
這些要背的單字
哇好多
他給我做好幾個禮拜
做成excel
excel
所以你可以觀察到
他還會啟用
Code interpreter功能
開始寫程式
然後幫你把它整理好的
14天每天20個多益進階單字
直接幫你生成一份
excel的檔案
再來呢
我們來直接一點的
直接來考試吧
測驗我一下
出考題這時候呢
身為一個壞學生
我們就會跟老師說
那
我不會直接給我答案
這邊我們就可以觀察到這個AI
其實他就會去逐步
拆解我們的問題
然後比如說他會用這個
先試著猜猜看
然後呢
他會去矯正我後續的這個
回答幫助我去做記憶
實際提起答對是你錯
哦哦哦哦
這樣子呢
我們就可以看出他其實會針對我們目前答題的狀況去幫我做一些分析
但是呢
我們發現他可以提供一個個人進度規劃的一個功能
比如說呢
我就可以跟他講說
我下週要考多益模擬考可以幫我規劃讀書進度嗎
好
所以呢
因為下禮拜就要考試了
所以他建議我們每天念書
他就會給我每天的單字跟練習庫的資源
非常的完美
我覺得可能還沒有到一個完美的老師
但是我覺得作為一個隨身的家教這一件事情上
他應該可以達成目前高中大學生等級
我覺得沒有什麼太大問題
現在你已經知道了這個學習與研究的功能究竟是在做什麼的
難道這就是這一集的全部內容嗎
哎
我們怎麼可能會輕易放過這個功能呢
接下來我們要跟各位分享
三個可以高效應用這個功能的小技巧
第一招直接把檔案丟進去
讓AI幫你拆解重點
你可以把你手上有的一些課本的檔案
電子檔、電子書
任何你想學習的內容
你可以丟進去讓確認GPT幫你拆解
然後讓他變成熟悉那個內容的老師
來去引導你把你那本要讀的課本把它吞下去
另外你也可以用手機直接翻拍你的課本
那當然唯一你要注意的事情是
要拍得夠清晰
要不然他在辨識文字的時候
其實有可能會出錯
第二招
沒有檔案怎麼辦呢
沒關係
我們還有Deep Research
你就直接打開Deep Research
請Deep Research去幫你搜尋相關的一些論文
報導、新聞
然後把這個結果的報告拿進來之後
再用剛剛上面那一招
把資料餵進去
請ChatGPT
幫助你把這些知識吞到你的腦袋裡面去
另外如果你擔心AI亂講話
下一句提示語
請針對這份資料的內容協助我學習
但內容可能有誤
請理解內容之後呢
再用你認為正確的方式教我
這樣子AI就不會照單全收
而是他會先思考篩選
再來做教學
第三招
善用專案工具
OpenAI雖然強調
學習研究的功能會記住你當前的內容
但說實話
每一次在開啟新的對話的時候
有時候他還是會有一點想歪
所以這時候呢
如果你是付費版的ChatGPT的用戶的話
你可以在旁邊開一個資料夾
一個專案的資料夾
把你所有的學習跟研究的東西
把它放到同一個專案資料夾裡面
這樣子
每一次回來學習的時候
AI都會根據你的這個專案的內容
來去回答你的東西
而不會從頭把所有東西從頭餵進去
這樣就可以有效的提高AI回答內容的正確性
我們自己在做測試的時候
還有發現
這個學習的功能呢
還有一個小撇步
你可以要求他幫助你完成一份
對老闆提案的計畫書
可能是可以請他當一個研究員
來去協助你
搜尋一些資料
然後引導你去把這些資料
堆到你的腦袋裡面去
然後生成一份
要對老闆生成一些報告
這個就留給螢幕前面的各位
如果你有把這個學習研究
找出一些有趣的新聞法
歡迎你在影片下面留言
跟其他的網友分享
最後呢
既然你都看到這個地方了
我們今天這支影片用的所有提示語
我們會放一個QR code在這邊
你可以直接掃描這個QR code
就當作我送你一個小禮物
不要跟別人說
看到這邊的人才有哦
那我們就下次影片再見囉
拜拜